par ces deux fouilles sont dans un
hôpital psychiatrique
et dans cet hôpital il y a une piscine
et les deux fous marchent au bord de la
piscine il y en a un des deux qui jette
dans la piscine il commence à se noyer
le deuxième il vague le sauve et tout et
en apprenant ça le responsable de
l'hôpital tu dis bah vu qu'il a fait ça
un acteéroïque je vais lui offrir sa
sortie je vais le laisser sortir donc tu
vas le voir dans sa chambre il écoute tu
as fait un acte héroïque c'est super ce
que tu as fait au moins tu es conscience
j'ai conscience que toi tu es conscient
je vais te laisser sortir de l'hôpital
ça c'est la bonne nouvelle par contre la
mauvaise nouvelle c'est que la personne
que tu as sauvé c'est pas ambiance
pour qu'il sèche
[Applaudissements]